[SPEAKING PORTUGUESE]
PAVNI DIWANJI: Welcome everyone.
My name is Pavni Diwanji,
I'm a VP of Engineering
here at Google.
And it is in an
incredible honor for me
to be introducing this
Women Techmakers Panel.
Women Techmakers, as
you probably know,
was formed by Natalie,
here, and Megan Smith, who
used to be one of our VPs
of [INAUDIBLE] who's now
CTO of US, to inspire, to
connect, and to celebrate
all the developers,
women developers, women
designers, women entrepreneurs,
all women in tech.
And we are-- we've
done a lot of events
to really shine the spotlight
on some incredible women.
The last one I had
the honor of attending
was at the International
Women's Day this year.
And I was blown away.
We had 10,000 women participate.
And it was a truly global event.
We had 128 places where
we hosted these events
across 50 countries.
So we have a huge
amount of momentum.
And it makes me incredibly proud
when I see the number of women
at I/O. I think we have grown it
four times in the span of three
years.
So it is truly a
huge achievement.
[APPLAUSE]
And last year we were at I/O,
I was right here on stage
introducing a robotics
panel, which was also equally
popular and well-attended.
And this year we have even
a more fun topic for you.
We have today a
balloon team, who--
which is one of our ambitious
Moonshot projects at Google.
And the question they're
attempting to answer
is, could we get everyone
connected on the net,
across the globe, no exceptions,
no matter how remote you are?
So with that, please join me.
I wanted to introduce two of
the extraordinary women of Loon.
One is Sam, who is
an aerospace engineer
and is working on the
simulation of balloons.
And Wanda, who's a senior
software engineer, and who's
the mastermind behind the
infrastructure of Loon's
mission control system.
So please join me in
welcoming them on stage.
Thank you.
SAMEERA PONDA: Thank you Pavni.
So, yeah, we're here
from Project Loon.
I'm Sam.
WANDA HUNG: I'm Wanda.
Hi.
SAMEERA PONDA: And we wanted
to tell you a little bit more
today about how we engineer
for the stratosphere.
This is the older
deck of our slides.
Sorry, one second.
This is the old deck.
WANDA HUNG: Sorry for
that interruption.
SAMEERA PONDA: So are you
guys enjoying I/O so far?
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
SAMEERA PONDA: [INAUDIBLE].
WANDA HUNG: [INAUDIBLE].
Just keep going.
SAMEERA PONDA: Do you want to?
I'd rather use the
right deck, but anyway.
OK.
I don't know what
version this is.
WANDA HUNG: We can just go.
Yeah.
SAMEERA PONDA: All right.
OK.
All right, so who here has
ever had bad reception?
Good.
So imagine never having
reception at all,
or having to climb a tree
like that boy in the video,
in order to be able
to get reception.
This is the type of
problem that we're trying
to solve at Project Loon.
We're trying to
bring internet access
to everyone in the world.
The video that you just
saw was from a demo
that we did in Brazil
last year in Agua Fria.
And there were these two
schools in the Amazon.
These kids had never
seen the internet before,
and for two weeks our
team went down there.
We flew a few balloons
over that area.
And these kids were
able to connect
to the internet
for the first time.
We actually did an
interactive geography lesson
in their class.
They were learning
about Portugal,
and they were able to pull
out some maps from Wikipedia
and some other resources online
to supplement their lecture.
And it was really amazing,
just seeing their reaction,
to be able to see what
the internet can really
provide for them.
And so that's part of
why we do what we do.
On this map here you
can see that these
are the areas of the
world that currently
have internet access, where
internet access is prevalent.
But most of the world
is still in the dark.
Two out of every three
people in the world
don't have access,
especially people living
in rural and remote areas.
So this is the problem that we
want to solve at Project Loon.
And access is really
important, because access
can provide so many
things at your fingertips,
like the world's information
at your fingertips.
All of the resources,
like health information,
educational opportunities,
tools for small businesses,
just things that you need
to be able to provide
for you and for your family.
And so the biggest problem
with bringing internet access
to rural and remote
areas is that
the current infrastructure,
such as cellular towers,
are really just
not cost effective
in some of these areas, or
just impossible to install.
Like being able to reach
islands and mountains and areas
that are very remote,
is very difficult
to do with just current
ground infrastructure.
And a lot of these areas,
the current solution
involve using satellites,
which are very expensive.
And most of the people
living in these areas
are just not able to
afford the connection
options that are there now.
So at Project Loon,
we decided to try
this radical new
approach, which is
to be able to fly
balloons that can float
in the stratosphere over
some of these areas,
and beam internet
down to the ground,
providing internet connection
at a fraction of the cost
of current infrastructure.
So how does Loon work?
The idea behind Loon is that
these balloons will float
over rural and remote areas.
And as they pass
over these areas,
users will be able
to connect directly
from their LTE handsets, so no
special antennas or anything
is needed.
You just need your
phone and you'll
be able to hook up
to Loon internet.
And as each balloon
flies over-- the balloons
actually move with the winds.
They're constantly in motion.
And so the balloons will be
floating over these areas.
But as one balloon
leaves, we have
to have another one
come and take its place.
Which means that we need
to adjust this entire fleet
of balloons as a network.
And in the stratosphere
we actually
have winds going in
different directions,
so depending on what
altitude we're flying,
we're able to catch
different currents of wind,
to be able to navigate
these balloons to areas
that we need to go.
So all of this takes a lot
of effort and computational
challenges.
And we built a mission
control infrastructure
that allows us to do
planning and simulation
and control of these balloons.
So that's the team that
Wanda and I work on,
and we're going to tell
you a little bit more
about that today.
So Wanda, she's one of the
senior software engineers
on our project, and
she's really awesome,
and she's going to tell you
a little bit about Mission
Control.
WANDA HUNG: Thank you, Sam.
[APPLAUSE]
So in my opinion, the coolest
thing about our project
is that we name our
balloons after birds.
Here is ibis, the
bird, and here's
our balloon that we built.
It's also named Ibis.
And we build it and launch
into the stratosphere.
It can go as high as 25
kilometers up in the sky.
It's about three times the
height of Mount Everest.
It gets pretty cold up there.
It can get below
80 degrees Celsius.
So we want to make sure that
our balloons can stay healthy.
We have also observed the
balloons going as fast
as 324 kilometers per hour.
It's about the same speed as the
fastest animal on the planet.
Does anybody have a
guess what that is?
Peregrine falcon can dive
down-- it's also another bird,
in case you don't know.
It dives to catch its prey
over 320 kilometers per hour.
So because it goes
so fast, and it
gets-- the weather condition
is so cold up there,
we want to make sure
that our balloons can be
tracked and also stay healthy.
So our team built a
mission control system
to monitor its every move.
So when I mentioned
mission control,
this is probably the view
that you have in mind, right?
Like maybe with some cheering
in the background, hey,
we launched the balloons.
But what we actually built is
a mission control system that
can run on workstations,
handheld devices,
and cellphones, so that
we can track Ibis anywhere
we go, at any time.
So it sounds simple enough,
but our mission control system
is actually quite complicated.
This is a flow chart of only the
high components of our system.
It can do communications
with the balloons, processing
telemetry, and it
can also monitor
the health of the balloon,
the simulation navigation
controlling the balloon,
and a simple UI that
will be able to help us to be
able to read it more carefully.
So here is a glimpse of
our mission control system.
As you can see, Ibis is
traveling across the Atlantic
Ocean heading towards
South America.
And the red line shows
the-- the red line
shows the historical path that
it has traveled in the last 24
hours.
And the pink line is
the predicted trajectory
of this balloon in
the next several days.
So we actually make
predictions, which
I'm going to talk about
later on in this talk.
So we want-- our
primary customer
for the mission control systems
are flight engineers, who
work 24/7 to monitor our
fleet of balloons in the air.
So we want to make
sure they're happy,
and we also want to make
their lives a little easier,
so they're not staying up all
night monitoring our balloons.
So we built several
features to enhance this.
So in this picture,
in this screenshot,
basically the lines here
represent the air traffic
control center boundary.
So they can monitor
and make sure
that our balloon,
Ibis, is not entering
another airspace anytime soon.
And when our mission
control system
detects that the balloon
is about to enter
another airspace, it
will automatically
generate a flight control plan
and email it to the next air
traffic control center.
And our flight
engineer on call will
be able to get an
automatic alert,
so they can start calling
the local authority
and start doing the
coordination to make sure
that they're aware of our
balloon entering their space.
So now that you have seen how we
track our balloons and monitor
them, we do have some stuff
that we cannot easily monitor
directly.
So Sam is going to tell you
a little bit about how we
diagnose these kind of cases.
Go ahead.
SAMEERA PONDA: Yes,
so as Wanda mentioned,
our balloons are 20 kilometers
up in the stratosphere.
The environment there
is very cold and harsh.
And we only really get
very limited information
from our sensors.
So we fly different sensors,
like GPS and pressure sensors.
But there's a whole
lot of other stuff
that we want to be able to
estimate about our balloon
state.
So I've been working on
different estimation algorithms
that we can use to try to figure
out things like temperature,
and how much gas we have
left in the balloon.
And I'm going to go over a
couple of these examples,
the more interesting
ones, I think, next.
So one of the most
important things
that we need to
figure out is how long
our balloons are going to
be able to last up there,
what is our balloon lifetime?
And since we want our balloons
to be able to last up there
for hundreds of days, we've
designed super pressure
balloons.
So this means that the
gas inside the balloon
is at a higher pressure
than the ambient,
and the gas
particles are pushing
against the walls of the
balloon, giving it its shape.
Now the pressure
inside the balloon
depends on both
temperature and the amount
of gas in the balloon.
When it's really hot, or
when there's too much gas,
the balloon could
potentially burst.
So it's really
important to know what
temperatures we're
going to expect
to see during the
course of our flight,
in order to decide how much lift
gas to fill the balloon with.
Conversely, when
it gets too cold,
or if we've lost too
much gas, the balloon
could actually lose
pressure, especially
at night time when it gets cold.
And it could essentially not
provide buoyancy anymore,
by not having its
fully inflated volume.
So this is also undesirable.
So we need to be able to monitor
these two quantities very
carefully.
But they're very
difficult to estimate up
in the stratosphere.
So the traditional methods
of measuring temperature,
like putting a thermostat
on your wall in your house,
don't really work
in the stratosphere.
We're above 95%
of the atmosphere,
so the air is really,
really thin up there.
So the thermostat on
your wall works mainly
through convection, air
rushing past the sensor
will-- you'll be able to
read the ambient temperature
of the air.
But for us, we're
measuring mostly radiation.
And so as the sun comes
up and shines directly
onto the sensor,
you're actually reading
more of the radiation
of the sun then
you are the lift gas
temperature inside the balloon.
So the red line
over here shows you
the readings from our
sensor, and the blue line
is actually closer to what
our balloon temperature is.
So the sensor's kind of
useless during the day,
which is a problem.
So in order to fix this,
I built this thermal model
that essentially takes in
all the sources of heat that
affect our balloon.
So things like the
radiation from the sun;
the earth, which is like a giant
space heater heating us up;
and then also interactions of
the balloon skin with the film.
So the way our balloon
temperature works,
it's similar to a car in a
parking lot on a hot day.
Like when you go to open
the door of your car,
it's really, really
hot inside your car
compared to the outside air.
So our balloons
similarly take in a lot
of the radiation of
the sun during the day,
and get really hot.
And then at night,
especially when
we're flying over
clouds, which block
the radiation from the earth,
we can get really, really cold.
So using all these
inputs together we
can actually model
very well what
the temperature the balloon is.
And once we know
temperature, we can actually
infer how much gas we have left.
And by tracking
this day after day,
we can see what
lift rates we have,
and project forward to see
how long our balloons are
going to last.
So here's a few
examples of the graph
that-- of the different
graphs that come out
of our estimation algorithms.
You can see
temperature on the top;
and then pressure as it
decreases over the balloon
lifetime and gas level;
and finally, the estimate
of how much lifetime
we have left.
Another really
important quantity
that we would like to know is
the state of our batteries.
Our balloons are 20
kilometers up in the air.
You can't really
plug them into a wall
and charge them overnight,
and so we actually
need to be able to provide
all of our own power.
So we fly solar panels that
can capture energy of the sun
during the day, and
store it in our batteries
to be able to operate all
of our systems at night.
And also do different maneuvers.
And monitoring our power is
actually really complicated.
Our systems are very complex.
We have several
different boards,
lots of different sensors, we
have batteries, we have solar.
And we also have
heaters on board
that turn on when it's cold.
And so predicting how much
all of these components
are going to consume
is quite difficult.
And then batteries are actually
very, very difficult to model
as well.
This curve on the
top here shows you
all of the different
discharge curves,
for the exact same
battery, but just
under different temperature
and load conditions.
And there's about
a 35% difference
in-- depending on whether
the battery's cold or hot.
So batteries do
not like the cold,
and actually perform
quite poorly in the cold.
And we need to be able to
estimate our temperature
for our battery, as well as
how much state of charge we
have left, under all of these
different varying conditions.
So my team and I build a
state of charge estimator
that actually works a lot
better than our old system.
Before, we used to use a
chip that was designed mainly
for cellphones.
It's very similar to the
chip that your cell phone
would use to tell you how
much battery you have left.
And the operating
conditions of our balloon
involve really, really
extreme temperatures.
So the chip was really
not performing very well.
So we had to build our own
in-house state of charge
estimator that performs a
lot better than the system
that we were using before.
And then the second
piece of this
is modeling how much
solar power we're
going to get from our panels.
This is actually
fairly complicated,
because it involves
trying to figure out
what the solar elevation will
be for different latitudes
and longitudes; how much the
atmosphere is going to affect
the solar radiation,
and how much attenuation
we're going to get from that;
what our balloon shadow is
going to look like.
So actually, when you
put it all together
you end up with this
Batman-looking curve,
where as the sun comes up, you
get more and more radiation
and less attenuation from
the atmosphere, which
causes the initial rise.
And then after a certain
level of elevation,
the balloon will actually
kind of come in the way
and cast a shadow on the panels.
So that causes the drop, the
ear of Batman in the curve
there that you see.
And so putting it all
together, we actually
have a fairly decent idea of
how much power we're going
to be generating and consuming.
And we can use this
in our simulations
to predict our power
budget, and how much we
have available for maneuvers.
So once we know what the health
and the state is of the system,
we also need to
be able to predict
where Ibis is going
to go, and how we're
going to navigate
to different areas
to be able to provide
continuous coverage.
So Wanda's going to tell you
a bit about our simulations.
WANDA HUNG: So in
order to navigate Ibis
to a desired location to
provide continuous coverage,
we have to first be
able to predict where
it's going to go in the future.
So by doing that, our balloons
actually fly with the wind.
So to do that, we actually
try to get information
like the wind data
from NOAA, which
stands for the National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration.
The data that we get from
NOAA is public information,
and it is available to pilots.
It tells us about the
speed and the direction
of the wind in the air
at different levels
of the stratosphere, actually.
So here's actually a
visualization of a wind map
that we built for cubic--
a small cubic area
in the sky, that basically tells
us where the wind is actually
going.
So we fetch the forecast wind
from NOAA every six hours,
and the data that we get
contains 16 days of data
in the future.
So basically we have
to build lots and lots
of these maps that
cover the entire surface
of the earth for the next
16 days, every six hours.
That's a lot of data
and a lot of processing.
But the good thing is
that we work for Google,
so we have a lot of
computer resources
that we can utilize here.
So here is a simulation
trajectory of Ibis.
The black arrows,
basically, point
is the wind direction and
the speed at that position.
And as you can see, the red
arrow's the movement of Ibis
as it flies with the wind.
So besides the position,
the altitude information,
and the wind data, we
also consider things
like the battery power,
the health condition
of the balloon, to determine
the balloon duration while we're
making this type of prediction.
With the knowledge
of the wind patterns,
and ability to navigate the
balloons to get to a desired
location to provide
coverage, we can basically
move the balloon up and down,
in this case, to do navigation.
So in this picture we
have a reachability map
that we built for Ibis,
at different levels
of the stratosphere.
So each one of these
paths basically--
each one of these
trajectories basically
represents the Ibis's path
at that altitude level.
And so basically at each
point of the computation,
we can decide which
level of altitude
we want to move Ibis to, to
get to a desired location.
So my team have actually
built lots and lots
of these algorithms,
to try to navigate
the balloons optimally.
So this one algorithm that
we use in this example,
is called the crazy
simple planner.
And what it does is simply uses
a form of heuristic spanning
tree search algorithm, to try
to find the most optimal path
from one location to another.
So in this case, we're
trying to find the cheapest
cost trajectory.
And it's defined by the user.
The cost can be defined as
either the destination that you
want to get to, or the
altitude band that you
want to keep the balloons at.
Or it can also be
the power consumption
to get to a location.
In this particular
example, we want
to try to find the shortest
path from Australia
to Christ Church in New Zealand.
So the white lines here indicate
all the possible trajectories.
And the red line is the one that
our algorithm, our crazy simple
planner, has selected to
be the most optimal path.
So everything
looks great, right?
We want to direct the
balloons to New Zealand,
and it's doing that.
But life is not
that simple, right?
Because the wind is forecast,
it's never totally accurate.
So we want to plan
for the uncertainty.
One of my colleagues actually
built a wind noise model,
that will be able to kind
of throw us off a little bit
when we're doing the
simulations and prediction.
So the red lines here represent
all the possible trajectories
at that altitude level, if we
are trying to simulate balloons
at that level.
And the blue line is for a
complete different altitude.
So for our stochastic
planning algorithm,
we tried to find the best
fit for that altitude
by throwing in some wind noise.
So now that we can navigate
Ibis to Christ Church,
what happens if it leaves?
Are we going to get
interrupted internet coverage?
We want to make sure that
when a balloon leaves,
another balloon,
let's say Merlin,
is going to come in and provide
coverage for the people below.
So we have to provide another
mechanism to flock entire fleet
of balloons from place
to place, in order
to provide continuous coverage.
So in order to validate our
fleet planning algorithm,
I built an analysis
planning framework
that will be able to-- sorry.
That will be able to
run a sizable fleet,
and simulate it,
and be able to do
some analysis over our
algorithms to make sure
that it's doing
what we're thinking
it's doing, under a
reasonable amount of time.
Because it's easier
to do simulations,
but it's not easy
to actually run
thousands and thousands
of these balloons
under a certain amount of time.
So in this example,
this is generated
by my planning framework, we're
trying to launch Australia.
We're trying to launch
out of Australia,
and to cover the
coverage in Chile.
And in this picture,
you can see the small--
like a couple dozen
balloons are coming out
of Australia, heading over to
Chile at different directions,
because the wind is actually
going different directions.
So this tool will help us to
be able to predict the wind
patterns at different
times of the year.
And we can also try to do this
in various different ways,
so that we can launch balloons
out of different cities
and be able to evaluate
the different launch
sites for our experiments.
And in this example,
we're flocking
the entire fleet of balloons
and trying to keep them
around the equator.
And Ibis is going out
of course a little bit,
so we-- our planning
algorithm actually
tried to redirect
it back on course.
So in our most recent
long distance LTE test,
we were able to launch one
balloon out of New Zealand.
And it went around the world,
over a 20,000 kilometers,
and be able to come in within
500 meters of ground distance,
and provide over two hours
of internet connection.
[APPLAUSE]
It was a huge
success for our team.
So in the future
we're hoping to fly
like thousands of
these balloons,
and be able to have
this kind of success.
But that also means we have
to hire more flight engineers.
So to make them happy,
we want to make sure
that we can actually automate
a process of navigating
our balloons.
So my colleagues and I
built an automation--
a flight automation
system, that will
be able to automatically
control the balloons to go
up and down, in order to
reach its prospective goals.
So with the system
that we've built,
we're hoping that it's a
small step toward providing
continuous coverage for
remote areas like Agua Fria,
that you saw earlier
in the video.
We want to bring
internet to every one
everywhere, like for
those kids that you saw.
We want them to learn, not
just as students, but also
as human beings in this world.
Like all of us here.
Thank you very much.
SAMEERA PONDA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
WANDA HUNG: So now
we're going to welcome
our moderator, Natalie,
and a few other ladies
from Project Loon to
answer a short Q&A.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Thanks.
Good job.
Really good job.
All right, so-- I think you
guys are right over here.
Go ahead.
We'll do a little dance.
Hey everyone, I'm Natalie.
Can we have another round of
applause for unexpected slides
popping up?
[APPLAUSE]
I think you navigated that just
as well as you do the balloons.
Very, very nicely done.
So my name is
Natalie Villalobos.
I run the Women Techmakers
program at Google,
as Pavni mentioned.
And the whole purpose
of Women Techmakers
is to increase the visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
And so I have the
pleasure of sitting down
with some of the
world's innovators
and sharing their
knowledge with you.
So we've collected some
questions from friends
out at I/O and on
the web, and I want
to get started with
a couple good ones.
So we've heard some of the
computational challenges
that you went over in the talk.
Can you tell me a bit about
the operational challenges?
And I'm going to skip back.
Who are you?
Let's start from the end.
MARIA: Hi, everyone.
My name is Maria.
I have been at Google
for almost four years.
And I joined Project
Loon last July
as a technical program manager,
working on the avionics team.
TAMERON STUBER: Hi,
I'm Tameron Stuber.
I'm a program manager focused
on manufacturing operations
of Loon.
I've been on the project
for about three years.
OLIVIA: And I'm Olivia.
I work on scaling operations,
mainly at the intersection
between hardware and operations.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Now we can get started.
So.
Computational challenges.
But can you tell me some of
the operational challenges,
because this isn't
just a two woman show.
I mean, Loon is a huge team,
but specifically, some of you
focus on the operational side.
So can you speak to that?
OLIVIA: Sure.
Like I mentioned, I work
on scaling operation.
So one of the bigger challenges
is how do we actually
launch at scale.
Not only do we need to
figure out where in the world
we launch these from, by
studying ground weather
patterns; where wind
speeds are lowest,
so that our balloons don't
turn into giant spinnakers
when we launched them;
where it doesn't rain,
so our electronics don't
freeze; where there
isn't a lot of cloud cover.
So that's one big thing.
And then we also just
engineered something
called the bird house, which
is a 50-foot tall mobile boat
hoist that we engineered to
actually automatically launch
our balloons.
So taking our 45 minute,
15 person operations
crew down to four people,
monitoring our launching.
It's pretty incredible.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
It's like great sign
of optimization.
So what are the
challenges involved
in building the balloons,
actually constructing them,
the components that
have to keep them
in the air for
the next 100 days?
TAMERON STUBER: So
there's actually
a lot of challenges with
manufacturing the balloons.
There's a very small
industry of balloon makers.
There's only a handful
of companies that
are scattered across the world.
And the traditional
process for balloon making
is quite manual and artisan.
And nobody's ever really
had to build at the scale
that our project's demanding.
So we're quite literally
pushing the envelope
of current industry standards.
So once we graduated
out of being
just this harmless
science experiment,
as we used to call
ourselves, we really
started looking at how we can
really scale the manufacturing
process.
So we really started looking at
every industry for inspiration
of how to automate, how to
scale, how to improve quality.
Because these
balloons are massive.
They're about 45,000 cubic
feet, and they're made up
of 1.5 mil polyethylene.
So they're actually
a pretty fragile,
and they can be brought down
by just a small pinhole.
So a good comparison
that we like
to make of how we
manufacture this
is how you would
manufacture a parachute.
You can't really test it
right before you use it,
so you have to instill a
lot of quality processes,
all these control checks during
the manufacturing process
before-- so, to guarantee
that it will work.
So there's a lot of challenges,
and there's not really
this clear path laid out for us.
But honestly, that's
what makes it fun.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So, and these
are open for anyone
on the panel,
how do you get them
the last for so long?
100 days is a pretty long
time, and Mother Nature
is obviously also an obstacle.
So longevity, how do
we make it happen?
TAMERON STUBER: So kind of
what I just spoke about.
Honestly it's really having
this strong eye of detail.
We've pulled from a lot of--
just even paying attention
to-- so these were pretty
manual for the first year.
And we actually had
a team of people
that were building
these balloons
and actually having to
crawl on top of them.
So we realized that we were
getting these little pricks,
they were kind of in
the shape of toenails.
So we actually had them wear
these little fluffy fleece
sock.
So it's like that
little eye of detail,
of looking at everything
to get them to stay up.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And so, kind of arising
from the operational
creation side,
can you tell me what's your
favorite story about your time
being on Project Loon?
It's like nervous laughter.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TAMERON STUBER: I
mean, so there's
a lot that we can't share.
One that I can share
that was pretty hilarious
was actually-- so we actually
started building these balloons
in-house, by a team
of scrappy engineers
of different backgrounds.
And so we were building
the prototypes in-house.
And we'd get them
off the ground,
they wouldn't make it too far.
But as they started
kind of scouring
the distance of
the United States,
we were tracking one that had
kind of reached its farthest.
It was actually over Kentucky.
We started getting these
YouTube alerts of UFO sightings.
And actually in
their local news,
they actually were
having a UFO sighting.
And it had this
image of our balloon.
So that was one of
my fonder moments.
MARIA: There's actually
a whole website, I think,
dedicated to the--
TAMERON STUBER: You
guys should look it up.
MARIA: --the UFO sightings.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So I was
also told about Batman symbols.
SAMEERA PONDA: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I mean, you already
referenced Batman in your slide.
But I think that there's some
other story about Batman.
SAMEERA PONDA: Well,
so internally, we
call Sergey Batman, just because
he's kind of cool and awesome.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Sergey Brin.
SAMEERA PONDA: I
don't even-- yeah,
Sergey Brin, the Google founder,
who is in charge of [x].
And so, I'm not even sure
he's aware of the nickname.
But anyway, for April Fools'
Day, one of our UI engineers
changed all of the
symbols of our balloons
into Batman symbols.
So on our live
mission control map,
you could just see a
lot of Batman symbols,
instead of balloons.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Nice.
And cool.
I really like that.
So what, kind of flipping
back, what do you
characterize as your
team's biggest challenge?
So clearly, you're
testing, you're iterating,
and you're having
fun along the way.
But what are some of the
challenges that you face,
and what was a success
that eventually
overcame that challenge?
MARIA: Yeah, I
can take that one,
it speaks a little more
on the engineering side.
So the diversity
of work, as we have
heard from this
panel, that's required
to make Project Loon a
success is really enormous.
Sundar touched on this
yesterday in his keynote.
The biggest-- some of
the biggest challenges
are the balloon
duration, the range,
and the bandwidth of the signal
that we're trying we provide.
As well as balloon-to-balloon
communication.
So the last one is
particularly important
because, in order to meet
our really ambitious goals
of providing
internet for all, we
need to essentially create a
network of balloons in the sky,
just like there is currently
a network on the ground.
And the technical
challenges, to be
able to send and receive
signals between balloons
is one certain challenge.
But to be able to launch the
hardware, make it operational,
and provide the high
quality and high accuracy
signal 60,000 feet in the air
in environmental conditions
that are essentially
alien for us,
that's a really,
really different ball
game, essentially.
But we're making it happen.
We proved that it works.
And as some would put it,
it's frickin' awesome.
Pretty good.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So when--
I was talking to Pavni earlier,
and she focuses on our
Google for Kids effort.
And we're doing a lot this year.
We did last year, we
did and I/O Youth,
where we engage young minds
into what we're all developing.
Because they're going to
grow up, and they're going to
inherit this world from us.
I
To those young people that
might ask this question,
did you always want to
be an aerospace engineer?
What did you want to be
when you were younger?
What did you think you
would grow up to be?
SAMEERA PONDA: Well I never
really wanted to grow up.
And fortunately, as a Google
engineer, I haven't had to.
But yeah, I know.
I always really liked
math and science.
And I didn't really
know what engineering
was when I was in school.
I figured I wanted to be a
physicist or a scientist.
And after going to college
and just kind of checking out
some of the
engineering classes, I
found it a lot more appealing
to have science as applied
to making something,
something tangible.
Where it really feels like
you're playing with toys.
You're building and
creating something new.
And so yeah, I fell in love
with engineering right there.
WANDA HUNG: So for me, I
was actually pretty mad
all through half of
my college years.
And then I took computer
science classes, as an elective,
and I loved it.
So it was really interesting.
And I just continued
down that path.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Olivia?
OLIVIA: So I wanted to
be professional horseback
rider when I was
a kid, which makes
sense why I'm at Google now.
But I didn't want to
specialize in anything.
And being on a team that's
doing something that's never
been done before makes
me come to work and get
challenged every day,
and learn something new.
And I get to try everything.
And that's really satisfying.
So I haven't had
to grow up, either.
TAMERON STUBER: Well actually,
I wanted to be a fashion
designer since I was eight.
And that's actually what I
went to school for, and worked
in the fashion industry
for the first couple years.
But it just wasn't quite right,
and wasn't quite feeding me
in the way that I
wanted it to feed me.
So I stayed really open,
and was just trusting
and hoping that the right
thing would come forward.
And actually my apparel
construction skills
were what led me to get
recruited onto this project.
So I thought it
was a good lesson
of following your
passions but staying open,
and not always having
to have it figured out.
So, it's been great.
MARIA: Yeah, I didn't know
what I wanted to be either.
When I was in school,
I was just one
of those people that try
to do-- try to do my best
and just work extremely hard.
But one of the qualities,
I guess, that I've had
and I have kept, is
just really being
open to different opportunities,
different experiences,
trying to be
flexible in that way.
So I remember a kind
of a turning point
for me was back in high school.
My junior-- after
my junior year,
the summer, that
summer there was
a program that was sponsored
by the New Jersey government
at Rutgers University
called the Governor's School
of Engineering and Technology.
So being part of that
one month long program
was kind of the first
time that I got exposed
to engineering principles.
I was taught how to--
you know, the concepts
of abstraction and
logical thinking
that comes with programming.
And also how to build
something physical.
We were using Lego Mindstorms.
That really attracted
me to the sort of field.
Also doing that
together in a team,
and I was kind hooked
on tech since then.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Wonderful.
So I know I speak
on behalf of Pavni,
and thank everyone in this room.
Thank you so much for leading
this new field of innovation.
And we look forward to
seeing more of what you
create in the years to come.
Thank you.